tomorrow some ccsd pre-k through third
graders return to campus for the first
time
in almost a year it's a major step for
students and families
as well as staff and tonight we're
tracking how both are preparing for the
big day
we start with reporter kristen drummond
tonight who's been speaking with
families ahead of the first day back to
class
kristin sasha some are comparing this
return to campus
as it's like the first day of school one
family in the northwest valley invited
me to see
how they're getting ready for the start
of hybrid learning
she finally gets to use her backpack
packed up and ready to go
she's got her little mouse for her
computer and then just some pencils
ari o'brien prepares for her daughter's
first day back on campus in nearly a
year i think it will be a nice change
for her
making sure she has the necessities and
a few other items
not needed in the past i gave her three
masks
and i labeled the bag clean just in case
she you know drops it how do you feel
about going
back to school tomorrow in person very
very very very 100 more
very excited addie attends gerheim
elementary school
the eight-year-old was placed in cohort
a for hybrid learning
she will attend her second grade classes
on monday and tuesday
in person then continue her studies
remotely wednesday through friday
i mean it will be nice for her to be
able to interact with the teacher
in person and see other students we're
just ready for them to get back get back
in the routine
and not be stuck at home anymore alondra
reynolds also looking forward to this
opportunity
her first grade daughter goes to hayes
elementary school the six-year-old is in
cohort b
attending class remotely monday through
wednesday and in person thursday and
friday
he's a little concerned with that
because by the time thursday and friday
hits
she's so tired from the week but
reynolds says
she welcomes this chance for some
normalcy she's excited about returning
with her
friends that's a big deal expect
elementary school students participating
in hybrid learning for at least the next
month the district plans to then
transition to full-time
in-person learning five days a week on
april 6th for pre-kindergarten
to fifth grade reporting live in the
newsroom kristen drummond 8 news now